hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast protein sample evaluation
using the nanodrop one uv-vis
spectrophotometer it is presented by
bulla koto Yanni PhD the product
marketing manager for nanodrop
instruments at Thermo Fisher Scientific
I am Judy O'Rourke of laberd's and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
root and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific for more information about
our sponsor visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor
Mew want during the presentation just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and type
your questions into the drop-down box it
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please use the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Koda Yanni
I will now turn the presentation over to
her
hello everyone thank you for joining us
in today's presentation we will cover
protein concentration measurements and
in particular measurements using the
nanodrop instrument we will go over some
of the basics of direct measurements
with a 280 and a 205 we will talk about
colorimetric asses did you know that we
can do color metric asses on nanodrop
one yes we can and we can even measure
little proteins I will end with best
price that practices and tips
most typing workflows required accurate
determination of protein concentration
there are multiple techniques for that
purpose both direct and indirect methods
each of these techniques has advantages
limitations and specific requirements
the most commonly used method is
absorbance at 280 nanometers
it is popular because it's very simple
to use very straightforward to perform
and another method is absorbance at 205
nanometers this method is based on
absorbance of the peptide bond and all
proteins have peptide backbone so it
applies to even proteins that do not
have tryptophan so terracing
there are also indirect methods for
evaluating protein concentration a for
those methods you have a dye that
interacts with the protein to treat
produce a dye protein complex and that
complex absorbs light for the
colorimetric acids or fluorescence for
the fluorescence acids and then by
measuring the complex you can calculate
the concentration of the protein
let's talk about making protein sample
evaluation with the nanodrop
spectrophotometers many of you probably
are already using mana drop instruments
but some of you may not
they're just two key things that I want
to talk about mana drop instruments one
of course that most people know is the
fact that you can measure without using
it you vet nanodrop instruments have
unique pedestal technology that lets you
pipette your sample you can type at 2
microliters of protein directly on the
measurement surface which I will refer
to as the pedestal and then when you
close the arm the sample is drawn into a
liquid column using surface tension and
optical fibres transmit the light from
the source the light source which is a
xenon lamp through the column to the
detector and that's how you receive you
see a spectrum after the measurement
it's very easy to clean up the sample is
simply wiped off and that there is no
carryover
an equally important aspect of manager
technology and one that not everybody
realizes is the fact that by not using
cuvettes we can control the path length
the person is in a cuvette is fixed it's
usually 10 millimeters but with nanodrop
instruments we use a patented autorange
path length technology and in fact every
sample is measured at multiple path
lengths for the knowledge of one it's 5
path lengths the shortest of which is 30
microns 30 microns is about half the
thickness of a piece of paper so what
does it mean to be able to measure at
very short path lengths it means that
you can measure very concentrated
samples since the concentration is
measured by using the beer-lambert
equation that you see here the path
length is part of this equation and when
the path length is shorter we can
measure very very concentrated samples
and what that means is that you the user
never have to worry whether your
instrument or your sample is within the
dynamic range of the instrument because
essentially you always are within the
dynamic range of the instrument
the manager of one and one C is our
latest knowledge or product these
instruments was were launched in late
2015 and they are they have some very
special features the in comparison to
other manager product the most important
one I think is that you don't need a PC
to run these instruments anymore
there is a touchscreen interface and you
can control the instrument from the
touch screen another very very important
feature for the nanodrop one is the
Eclair own software a claro software
identifies contaminants in samples in
both nucleic acid and protein samples
and gives the corrected concentration
and I'll talk about that a little more
later on in my talk this is a very
modern instrument with enhanced
connectivity you can connect to a
printer via Wi-Fi you can connect your
computer via Wi-Fi and send your data to
your computer so that you can analyze it
later on at your desk you can save your
data to the thermo Fisher cloud and
every customer every none of the
customer can obtain for free 10 gigs of
memory on the thermo Fisher cloud
and to the dynamic range for the system
and is huge you can measure up to 400 or
more mix per mil of IgG
and we have the knowledge of one that
has the pedestal only and another model
is the knowledge of one see that gives
you the pedestal microphone and
capability as well as the cuvette
capability
the negative one has multiple hard-coded
applications for protein quantification
all the applications live under the
protein pad here you can see the
proteins home screen and the other three
images on the slide show you what the
data looks like when you collect when
you measure proteins with a 280
these are measurement screens from
proteins and labels and from the BCA a
colorimetric assay
you can of course measure proteins on
our other nanodrop instruments the
nanodrop light is the most basic and
smallest model we have you can fit it
essentially in the palm of your hand and
this instrument does not provide
spectral data it it is based on two LED
lamps one and two sixty and one and two
eighty so you can collect quick a two
eighty measurements for pure protein
samples
the other two instruments the negative
2000 and the 8000 both require PC to
operate and there are both full spectral
instruments and have xenon lamp as the
light source the nanodrop 8000 is our
higher throughput instruments you can
measure up to eight samples at a time so
you can actually do a 96-well plate by
loading eight samples on the eight
pedestals at a time people that are very
good at this can actually do a 96-well
plate in five to six minutes the output
from the nanodrop 8000 includes spectra
for every sample for all eight samples
at a time
the wise use not a drop usually
spectrophotometers of course the micro
volume capability is very important you
don't waste precious sample you can
measure just from four proteins is 2
microliters of sample it's very fast and
easy to measure you never need to make
delusions because you're always within
the dynamic range of the instrument and
Aleutians not only take time but they
also introduce errors so that is
important these instruments are designed
for life scientists so you have other
applications that may be of importance
to you you have an 8 to 60 application
for example as well as just a very basic
u disease application for the knowledge
of one via claro sample intelligent
technology can give you a lot of
information about the quality of your
sample and it's excellent value for the
customer because you don't need to buy
disposables or cassettes
okay now let's talk about protein
quantification using absorbance at 280
a little bit about the basics of UV
absorbance you see absorbance is an
analytical method that relies on
measuring a light beam as it exits a
solution you collect a spectrum that
tells you how much the solution actually
absorbed and these spectra give us both
qualitative and quantitative data
qualitative data because the spectral
fingerprint tells us what molecules are
present in the sample and quantitative
data because at a given wavelength the
absorbance is proportional to the
concentration of the absorbing molecule
in that sample and then you can use the
beer-lambert equation to calculate the
concentration from the absorbance at
that wavelength
proteins are absorbed at 280 and because
they have amino acid that has a romantic
side chains and they absorb around 280
tryptophan is the most important amino
acid for a 280 because it has the
highest extinction coefficient in other
words it absorbs the strongest of all
amino acids but tyrosine also
contributes the 15 disulfide bonds
contribute and selleth phenyl alanine
contributes to a smaller degree
so a typical on the right bottom right
here you can see a typical protein
spectrum and we'll show you a peak at
280 and also a strong absorber from the
best peptide backbone a little lower at
around 200
so from 8 to 80 measurements absorbance
a to 80 we can calculate the
concentration using a beer lambert
equation as i said so the beauty lambert
equation says that a to 80 equals
concentration times a specific factor
that's protein specific that's called
absorption or extinction coefficient
times the path length that the distance
that the beam travels through the sample
this epsilon value is a very very
important number epsilon is the
wavelength dependent absorption
coefficient it can be molar or we can be
mass and we'll talk more about that it
is based on the amino acid sequence and
it is different for every protein
unlike nucleic acid samples where if you
have double-stranded DNA the epsilon is
a factor that's the same for all
double-stranded DNA let's pop the case
for proteins for proteins
every protein has its own distinct
epsilon value
a couple of other things that will be
good to keep in mind when we use direct
hOAT measurements calculation assumes
that the protein is pure in other words
it assumes that all the absorbance at
280 comes from this protein in reality
there sometimes other contaminants in
the sample and everything in the sample
that absorbs it 280 nanometers will
contribute to that age rating what can
that be nucleic acids absorber 260 which
is nearby some buffers and detergents
also absorb nearby something else to
keep in mind is that the secondary and
tertiary structure of the protein can
affect the absorbance
so sometimes spectra from the same
protein can look different when the
protein is dissolved in different
buffers
let's talk a little bit about epsilon
extinction coefficients they come in two
flavors and they come as the mass
extinction coefficient which is
essentially the absorbance of the ten
MiG's per mil solution
but so these numbers can be determined
empirically but coefficient values for
many many projects have been compiled
and are available in the literature so
you usually just look them up
in addition to the math coefficient you
can have a molar extinction coefficient
or absorptivity coefficient and that is
the molarity of the protein solution
that gives you a 1 absorbance unit
these these two flavors of extinction
coefficients are related to each other
so if you know the molecular weight you
can convert one tweet to the other
manager makes it very easy for you to
select the correct extinction
coefficient and when you are doing a
measurement you will be asked to select
a sample type so what is the sample type
the sample types tells the instrument
what extinction coefficient to use to
calculate project protein concentration
from 8 to 80 remember years law years
law knows that L knows the path length
of the instrument knows the absorbance
but to calculate the concentration in
needs to know which epsilon value to use
and that is what you do when you select
the sample type
the proteins from that drop-down box
gives you a range of extinction
coefficient of course if your sample is
idg it's very easy you select IgG which
would be a useable mass coefficient form
of mammalian I - jeez but also if you
know that your protein has an epsilon
value of near seven and I think it would
be smart to pick BSA as your sample type
because that means that the calculation
will be using an epsilon of six point
six seven
so these proteins give you a range of
extinction coefficients that you can use
now if you know your molar coefficient
you can enter it under other proteins e
epsilon and molecular weight but you
have to enter the molecular weight in
this case so that the instrument can
calculate the mass coefficient for you
and if you know the mass coefficient you
can just enter it under other protein
epsilon 1%
sample type ensures that the correct
factor is used in the calculation of the
protein concentration so what I have
here is an example that illustrates the
importance of using the correct absolute
value
and so we have a sample that has an
absorber for 280 of to the first
calculation uses BSA as the sample type
and uses a mass coefficient of 6.7 the
concentration result would be 3 the
second one Jesus rgg so the
concentration will be 1.5 half as much
because the mass coefficient is 13.7
compared to BSA so you can see this way
how epsilon can affect your your
concentration result
absolute values range from 4 to 24 so if
you have a sample that's a mixture of
proteins or to pure proteins that you
don't really know the extinction
coefficient or you only need an average
value or an estimate of the protein
concentration we have an option that one
absorbers equal equals 1 make 4 mil that
you can use and this one is based on an
excellent mass extinction coefficient of
10
this table gives you more detailed
information about the sample type
options the nanodrop gives you I've
included this for your restaurant
reference in case you want to look at
the details at a later time
you
on banana trip 1 we have added a new
feature that we believe will make
protein scientists life a lot easier and
that new feature is the protein editor
what the protein editor does it allows
you to customize your sample type
drop-down list so the way it works is
from the home page you can tap on the
Settings icon and then you select the
protein editor the protein editor then
has a plus sign there if you tap on the
plus sign you will be prompted to add
information about your protein such an
extinction coefficient molecular weight
and so on any name you can call it my
favorite protein or my fibronectin or
whatever and then when you save that
that entry then your favorite protein
will become part of that drop-down box
and you can select it every time you
make a measurement this should save a
lot of time and also reduce error due to
typos and so on
before you do any measurement you have
to blunt the instrument and you usually
black with the buffer that your protein
is dissolved in
with the negative one when you blank you
do not see a spectrum appearing on the
screen but the blank spectrum is
collected and it is saved in their
instrument memory and then it is
subtracted from each measurement each
subsequent measurement until you do
another block this way the buffer
contribution to absorbers is removed and
the sample spectrum that we see it
really is all due to the absorbance of
the protein in the sample it is
important that you black with a buffer
that is the same buffer that you have
used to make the protein solution from
the same bottle if at all possible
today's baseline correction is something
completely different when you set up an
experiment on and run a drop instrument
you have to you see that you have a
baseline correction set at 340
nanometers and you can D deselect that
if you don't want it so the baseline
correction is used to correct for any
light scattering that's caused by the
sample itself sample sometimes of micro
bubbles or particulate that can create
scattering light scattering the sample
and that can affect the absorbance so
what essentially does it normalizes each
spectrum to a specific point in the
spectrum by subtracting the absorbance
at that wavelength and that wavelength
for proteins is 340 nanometers where
absorbance is minimal for protein
samples now if you have a sample that
for some reason absorbs strongly at 340
you should turn the baseline correction
off otherwise you will see in under
estimate of the absorbers
talk about buffers when measuring
concentration using a 281 should
consider the protein sample buffer and
the buffer zone the first row of here
that are you see spectra of PBS heats
and chats
these are buffers that you would
consider good with touka measurements of
these buffers blanking first with water
and you can see that these buffers are
pretty pretty flat around 280 even
though they do have some absorbance in
the low UV ripple buffer does absorb
quite strongly in the low UV especially
around 280 so Ripa is not recommended as
a buffer for a 280 quantification now
when you are in doubt whether your
buffer is is good to use in measuring 8
to 80 you can evaluate your buffer
yourself by blanking with a with water
and then measuring looking at the
spectrum of the buffer and seeing if you
have absorbance around the area the
wavelength of interest
what happens if you do use Ripa better I
have some examples here of measuring a
BSA solution and the first one in Figure
one on the Left we have a BSA solution
in PBS and the black watch PBS as well
you can see a typical correct absorbance
spectrum that has a trough around 240 to
260 and a peak around 280 in Figure 2
the red arrow shows you a spectrum of
BSA in Rippa buffer with blanking in
water this particular solution the
actual true concentration is 16 mix for
milk but the the reported concentration
is going to be 33 mix per meal because
there is a lot of contribution from Reba
at this wavelength in fact this green
arrow show you a spectrum that's just
Ripa only and you can see how much
absorbance we have if you like with Ripa
as well in order to measure a sample
that's in Ripa buffer then you get a
spectrum like then figure 3 which shows
you that you basically wipe out all
absorbance so it's best to not use Ripa
buffer for 8 to 80
making measurements a to ating
measurements on the nanodrop one is very
very simple you select the protein 8 to
80 application from the home screen you
blank the instrument with a buffer you
will see you pick yours you select your
protein type your sample type and then
you close the arm and you will see your
measurement here on the a - 18
measurement screen the data that you
will see is concentration the absorbance
is 280 and then you will see another
number excuse me you will see another
number which is the ratio a to 60 over a
to 80
this is a purity ratio a protein purity
ratio for those of you is that work with
nucleic acids the term purity ratio
should be very familiar to 60 over 20 to
60 over 230 ratios that give you
information about nucleic acid purity in
a similar way the 260 over to 280 in can
give you information about purity of
your protein sample in fact this ratio
is very sensitive to nucleic acid
contamination if you have nucleic acids
5% of nucleic acid almost doubles your
purity ratio but for the number of one
in addition to this purely ratio the
eclair of sample intelligence technology
will give you a lot of information about
your sample
and this is how a Clara works
you
on the left here we have a measurement
screen we have a protein sample that has
been flagged with a contaminant alert
that's that yellow triangle there
if you tap on the yellow triangle you
will see the contaminant analysis screen
on the right so what this screen tells
you this has a lot of information it
tells you that although the original
concentration of the sample was 5 mix
per mil a claro has detected that there
is a lot of nucleic acid in the sample
that contributes to point 59 absorb mix
per mil and that has to be subtracted
and to give you the true concentration
of the sample the corrected
concentration which in this case is the
one name per mil
so a Clairol can detect nucleic acid in
proteins and give you corrected
concentration for those of you that may
be working with nucleic acids as well
a Klara is a very very useful feature
because it can detect protein phenol and
quality results in DNA and RNA samples
and give you corrected concentration
saving you a lot of time from
troubleshooting headaches
talk a little bit about protein a 2:05
protein 805 is a new feature on banana
drop 1
it was used as a custom method on the
knowledge of 2000 but we had a lot of
interest in it so we added it as a
pre-configured application on the
nanodrop one
absorbance at 280 as you just discussed
requires tryptophan and tyrosine
residues but not all proteins all all
proteins have tryptophan and tyrosine
residues especially small peptides often
may lack spirit of tyrosine and
tryptophan so a25 is based on the
absorbance of the peptide bond and
that's present in all proteins because
all proteins have a peptide backbone in
fact a two-five is much more sensitive
than a 280 because on average the molar
absorptivity at 205 are much higher
about 30 times higher than the molar
absorptivity at 280 the icky feel though
for a 205 measurements is that protein
buffers absorb strongly in the low UV
and it's very hard to find a buffer that
does not absorb for customers that want
to make measurements at 8:05 we
recommend that they use a low absorbing
buffer such as the bridge lysis buffer
that absorbs minimally in the low UV
so when you open the 805 application you
are going to be asked to select one of
three methods method one is to be used
for peptides that have no trip defense
or tyrosines and this method uses an
extension coefficient of 31 to do the
calculation of the concentration from
absorbance at 205 if your protein
contains significant amounts of
tryptophan and tyrosine residues you
should be using the scopes method
the scopes method takes into account the
significant absorbance of tryptophan and
tyrosine at 2:05 and uses a ratio in its
equation to correct for the sidechain
absorbance
if you already know the exact extinction
coefficient of your protein at 205 and
you can find that actually using
calculation tools that you can find
online you can use the third method
which is the custom method
you can also run protein colorimetric
asses on the nanodrop instruments
Allura metric assays are commonly used
to measure protein concentrations of
impure protein mixtures or cell lysate
and they require a standard standard
curve it is very easy to to measure to
do standard curves on the nanodrop one
pedestal
here we are looking on the right at
[Music]
setting up such a measurement you can
get to pick your curve type the
replicates you're going to use and you
can enter your your the concentrations
of your standard curve on the bottom
right here you can see a measurement
screen at the end of the BCA essay the
white circles here are the standard and
the red are the samples and for the
upper right here you see the results you
can see the concentration result as well
as the absorbance at 562 nanometers we
have many protocols and application
notes or colorimetric acids I've
included some links to them here but you
can find many many of them on our
website
this table is for you to use as a quick
reference it includes the concentrations
protein concentrations that you can
measure using the nanodrop pedestal as
well as advantages and things to
consider for each passe
proteins and labels application one uses
the proteins and labels application to
quantitate label proteins those of you
that use the knowledge drop to measure
nucleic acids this is the protein
analogue of the microarray education
with the proteins and labels education
you can quantitate both the carrier
protein as well as one and up to two
dice so for example a lot of of our
customers use it to evaluate label
incorporation in your sample now I want
to make it clear that knowledge of
knowledge of instruments do not measure
fluorescence there spectrophotometers
they're not fluorometers but a lot of
dyes also absorb in the visible and
numbers of spectrophotometers use this
absorbance to calculate dye
concentration on labeled proteins to
make depart the such a measurement you
select a sample type like you would for
the protein and that is going to be used
for the calculation of your protein
concentration and then you can select
dyes and units and you select dyes from
a drop-down list and we the instrument
comes with a number of preset dyes but
we have a feature that allows you to
customize the diameter and I will talk
about that in a minute
first I want to show you here a
measurement screen this is a size 5
labeled antibody so you can see that you
get two peeps three actually but there
is one peak at 280 from the antibody and
one peak at 500 which is from side 5 and
then your result includes the
concentration both of your protein and
the dye
so as you can do with the protein editor
you can customize the diameter as well
so you can access it through the
settings menu again from the home screen
and you can go in hit the plus and you
will be prompted to add some information
as well as the name for your guy you can
also remove that if there's dyes on the
drop down menu that you know you'll
never use you can deselect them and they
will not appear and then enter your own
dyes the one that you use and you can
get all this information like it
coefficient and wavelength or it absorbs
you can get almost from from the dye
supplier now it's important that the dye
select must fall between 450 nanometers
and 700 nanometers if you have a dye
outside that range you can still do a
measurement a proteins and labels
measurement but you cannot really do it
within this application you will have to
create a custom method to do it and our
tech support team can help you do that
we have custom methods available on our
website for measuring a number of
molecules such as hemoglobin glucose
nanoparticles chlorophyll the peers
rapid gold BCA which is a new color
metric assay you can use that as you can
find out among the custom methods on our
website so what is the custom method
this is a method that can be uploaded to
your to the onboard control of the
nanodrop one and then you select it and
then you can use it as any other
application to do your experiments
feel free to contact our manager of
technical support team to ask questions
about custom methods and to get help
creating new custom methods we do that
for customers all the time
I want to talk a little bit about and
best practices for nanodrop using
monitor pyramids for proteins it's very
important to measure 2 microliters again
those of you that may be doing nucleic
acid measurements you can go as low as 1
microliter for nucleic acids but
proteins have surfactants and detergents
in them that affect the surface tension
and it's important to use adequate
volume to make sure you make a good
column for measurement but remember the
concentration calculations are really
volume independent before you measure
make sure your sample is homogeneous or
taxied warm it up a little bit this is
especially important if your sample is
very concentrated use a fresh aliquot
for every measurement make sure you
don't have little bubbles in your sample
maybe do a quick spin trying to prior
prior to measuring make sure you blank
with the appropriate buffer make sure
your pedestals are clean occasionally
the pedestals will need
to be reconditioned especially for when
you use you do a lot of protein
measurements and as I said proteins have
detergents in them detergents tend to
decondition their pedestals and you know
that you your parasol stick on the
unconditioned because the the sample
does not bead on it it will look flat in
that case you just have to get the pr
one kit that we offer and it's a very
simple procedure to recondition your
pesto
okay I've come to the last slide here
this is a table that gives some basic
information and how do I know what is
the best method to quantify my protein
sample I pretended for different methods
hi how do we know which one is the best
this this table gives you some clues for
example for direct measurements at a 280
and a 205 your protein must be pure if
you have a cell lysate colorimetric or
fluorescence assay may be better because
the sample does not have to be pure
think of your buffer and buffer
compatibility with assays think of the
time that it will take you to set up the
assay the indirect at is require time
and for to do the reaction as well as to
create a standard crush disable just
gives you some things to consider this
is my last slide thank you very much for
joining me
thank you dr. koto Yanni
formative presentation we will now start
the live Q&A portion of the webinar
Patrick Brown from the technical support
team will join bulla to answer questions
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question and this week
I had a crude protein extract and wanted
to determine protein concentration
accurately for bioassay
would do two colored components with
within the extract the Bradford methods
failed to give an accurate result what
other option is there to determine the
concentration
you
okay thank you for this question it's a
good question I'm going to let Patrick
from our tech support team answer it
Patrick please thank you
so absorbance spectroscopy really cannot
differentiate between molecules
absorbing at the same wavelength for
accurate quantitation the sample really
needs to have only one molecule in it
absorbing light at that particular
wavelength of interest the quantitation
wavelength or as we call it the analysis
wavelength for this individual the first
thing I would recommend is to use the UV
vis application this will give you a
make a measurement of your sample in the
UV vis application and this will give
you an idea of what wavelengths your
sample absorbs light at and then
consider looking at some of the other
colorimetric assays for which we have
hard-coded applications such as the BCA
or the lowry would appear six sixty and
see if any of those wavelengths specific
for those reagents in your sample have
minimal absorbance and so that would be
the best option now in the event that
those reagents the wavelengths at which
quantitate those reagents there's also
absorbance in your sample you may need
to think about purifying your protein
out of your extract or alternatively
choosing a different method to extract
proteins such that there's not so much
absorbance in the visible spectrum next
one is my colleagues measured DNA and
RNA on their nanodrop can I measure my
protein samples without harming their
measurements and okay that is a good
question in which one that we hear quite
often yes you can absolutely make
protein measurements and DNA and RNA
measurements on the same instruments if
that when you finish your measurement
with the proteins you can simply wipe
the pedestal with a lint-free laboratory
wipe
to prevent carryover was something that
one could do if one is worried that and
wants to make very clean the pedestals
really well is to use PR one to
recondition the pedestals we have
methods of how to more thoroughly clean
the pedestal if you're truly worried but
that will take a while before your
pedestal is is affected by too many
measurements with proteins so bottom
line yes you can absolutely measure your
proteins on the same instrument thank
you um some of my samples are negative
what does that mean and how do I fix it
yes that's another very good question
so negative absorbance means that your
blank is absorbing more than your your
actual sample and again I would like to
Patrick talk talk about this in more
detail sure
so as vola mentioned earlier in the
presentation when you make that blank
measurement this software is storing the
amount of sorbents through that blank in
the software and then when the sample
measurement is made the absorbance of
the blank is subtracted from the sample
so when your sample reads with negative
absorbance that tells us the blank
solution where the blank measurement had
more absorbance than the the sample
itself that can be caused because
perhaps there was something on the
pestle
it was the pedestal was dirty prior to
making that blank measurement or perhaps
even the the blank solution itself be it
water or some elution buffer somehow got
contaminated any time we see a negative
absorbance we recommend cleaning the
pedestals again you can use that PR one
solution that Bolin mentioned obtaining
a fresh source of your blank whether its
water or your elution buffer blank
instrument again and repeat the
measurement thank you
our next one is protein measurement
using hOAT sometimes shows poor
repeatability how do
and prove that
and that could be due to a
non-homogeneous
sample remember I talked about the
different tricks how it's important to
make sure that your sample is
homogeneous make sure your work vortex
your sample maybe you need to warm it up
so that that is the key reason that you
may see poor repeatability Patrick do
you have any more ideas about this
question I definitely agree with those
comments the other common things are
definitely used to microliters when
making protein measurements and also you
it's very important that you wipe the
pedestal between every measurement so
you would not want to make multiple
measurements of the same two microliters
sample for example you would want to
wipe the net wipe the pedestal go back
to your sample tube and take a fresh two
microliter aliquot time to make another
measurement and now those between two
microliters and using different alec
wants as well as the comments you made
whole look I think those are some good
places to start yes thank you both
what protein controls do you recommend
hmm well there are several BCA protein
controls that are Thermo Fisher
Scientific sells the best thing to do is
contact our tech support team we have
lists of standards that you can use
actually it's important that for example
when you do a colorimetric standard
curve that you have a standard that is
similar to to your protein that you're
trying to measure so for example if
you're measuring antibody it's better to
use IgG as a standard because they
behave in the same way ended by buying
protein in the same way so Patrick did
any more ideas on this question no I
think that was heard okay you proteins
me to be denatured to be measured on a
nano drop
Patrick why don't you answer that
sure proteins do not need to be the
nature to be accurately measured on
nanodrop instruments they certainly can
be one thing to consider when measuring
your proteins is that native folded
proteins do absorb light differently
than denatured proteins they may absorb
light more light or less light for the
same concentration so when you are
making your protein measurements you do
want to ensure that the extinction
coefficient you input into the protein
80 to 80 application was determined on
the same confirmation of your protein
whether you're measuring native protein
or denatured you want to make sure the
extinction coefficient matches what
you're measuring great looks like we
have time for one more question so it is
is it possible when using colorimetric
assay on nanodrop one to load previously
acquired or measured standard curve and
measure the protein concentration
without repeating the standard curve
measurement
Patrick I'll let you respond to this one
piece sure
so unfortunately at this time we don't
have that capability but we do know that
this is a highly requested feature and
we are working our software team is
aware of this feature and and so perhaps
in the future that will be available
yeah good well I would like to sorry dr.
Caudill Yannick we finished that's okay
so with our next software release we
would be adding some features that are
highly requested by our customers I
would like to once again thank dr. koto
Yanni for her presentation would also
like to thank Thermo Fisher Scientific
for making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through September of 2019 please share
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that is all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye